This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Ryan's Satan is opening up a storage unit in Austin, Texas. It's 10 feet by 5 feet with steel walls. Ryan's mom recently moved out of town and left her things with him. It's just crap to me. Lots of files she thought she would need. Lots of purses. It's probably like 10 purses.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。瑞安的妈妈正在德克萨斯州奥斯汀市清理一个储物单元。它有10英尺长、5英尺宽，墙壁是钢制的。瑞安的妈妈最近搬到了外地，把她的东西留给了他。对我来说，那简直就是垃圾。有很多她以为自己会用到的文件，还有很多钱包，大概有10个左右。
Why? Why 10 purses? I'm a firm believer and just shed your skin, get rid of it and start traveling light. But then Ryan stops. He's looking at a VHS tape, toning it over in his hands. It's a recording of a TV show that he was on when he was a child. He shakes his head. It's so like his mom to do this. And there's sentimental value, so it's hard to get rid of. She does it in abundance, just to maybe make her feel better.
为什么？为什么要留10个钱包？我坚信应该“脱胎换骨”，摆脱旧物，轻装上阵。但这时瑞安停了下来。他正看着一盘录像带，在手里翻来覆去地看。那是他小时候参加过的一个电视节目的录像。他摇了摇头。这太像他妈妈会做的事了。而且这东西有情感价值，所以很难扔掉。她留了太多这样的东西，也许只是为了让自己感觉好受些。
It's not just Ryan's mom. It's hard for many people to let go of their stuff. That's because the things we own can be imbued with deep meaning. This week on Hidden Brain, the complex psychology of what it means to own something and how our possessions reveal a great deal about us. When you move to a new home or a new city, you take your things with you. As you carry box after box out of your house, you might have an epiphany. You own a lot of stuff. Bruce Hood is the author of Possessed. Why we want more than we need.
这不仅仅是瑞安妈妈的问题。对许多人来说，放下身外之物都很困难。这是因为我们拥有的东西被赋予了深层的意义。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将探讨“拥有”的复杂心理，以及我们的财产如何揭示了关于我们自身的许多信息。当你搬到新家或新城市时，你会带上你的东西。当你把一箱又一箱的东西搬出房子时，你可能会突然意识到：你拥有的东西太多了。布鲁斯·胡德是《占有：为什么我们想要的超过了我们需要的》一书的作者。
He's a psychologist at the University of Bristol. He explores the psychology of ownership. He knows the answer to the question, you may have asked yourself during your last move. Why do I own so much stuff? Bruce Hood, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me, Shankar. You mentioned Bruce that there are about 50,000 storage facilities in the United States.
他是布里斯托大学的心理学家。他研究所有权的心理学。他知道你在上次搬家时可能问过自己的那个问题的答案：为什么我拥有这么多东西？布鲁斯·胡德，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你的邀请，尚卡尔。布鲁斯，你提到美国大约有5万个仓储设施。
There are even more storage facilities than Starbucks cafes or McDonald's restaurants. What does this reveal about how much stuff we have, Bruce? It's amazing, isn't it? It's a really strange phenomenon. It's fairly recent, I would imagine, as a consequence of the fact that our productions have increased as our manufacturing has really developed over the last couple of centuries. But we seem to be increasingly on this relentless pursuit of more and more things. And that's really what drove me to start writing a book about
仓储设施的数量甚至比星巴克咖啡馆或麦当劳餐厅还要多。布鲁斯，这揭示了我们拥有多少东西？这很惊人，不是吗？这是一个非常奇怪的现象。我想这在很大程度上是近期的事，因为在过去几个世纪里，随着制造业的真正发展，我们的生产力提高了。但我们似乎越来越陷入一种对物质的无止境追求。这正是促使我开始写这本书的原因。
what's the motivation behind it all. Yeah, what's interesting is that we don't just own stuff, but we often find ourselves bewildered that we own so much stuff almost as if we didn't have agency, you know, acquiring all the stuff ourselves. So, we look around us and we see, how could I possibly have collected all the stuff around me? Yeah, well, that's kind of the reasoning behind the title of the book, Possessed. And it's a play on words, because, on words because obviously, possessions are the things that we own.
这一切背后的动机是什么。是的，有趣的是，我们不仅拥有东西，而且我们常常对自己拥有这么多东西感到困惑，就好像我们自己并没有主动去获取这些东西一样。所以，我们环顾四周，心想：我怎么可能收集了周围所有的这些东西？是的，这正是书名《占有》背后的逻辑。这是一个双关语，因为显然，“占有”（possessions）是我们拥有的东西。
But I'm also alluding to the fact that it's as almost as if there's a sort of little demon inside us, which is compelling us to go for more and more things. It's like this irrational little monster who controls our consumption. I understand people have studied how much stuff we have in the context of studying fire hazards. So obviously the more stuff you have, the more stuff you have that's combustible. And you've cited an amazing statistic in your book. In the last 30 years, the time to what is called spontaneous combustion has gone down from
但我也是在暗示，这就像我们内心深处有一个小恶魔，在驱使我们去追求越来越多的东西。它就像一个控制我们消费的非理性小怪物。我知道人们曾在研究火灾隐患的背景下研究过我们拥有多少东西。显然，你拥有的东西越多，可燃物就越多。你在书中引用了一个惊人的统计数据：在过去30年里，所谓的“自燃”时间已经从
28 minutes to 4 minutes. What is this telling us, Bruce? Well, we've got too many flammable things in our house, but it's literally, there's just too many things that we're accumulating. And in fact, a lot of the stuff we have, we've overspilled into our garages, but most garages these days don't contain the cars anymore.
28分钟缩短到了4分钟。布鲁斯，这说明了什么？嗯，我们的房子里有太多易燃物品了，但实际上，这只是因为我们积累的东西太多了。事实上，我们拥有的很多东西已经溢出到了车库里，但如今大多数车库里已经放不下车了。
They're on the sidewalk. People are literally moving in the full one room, and then they have to put it into the garage to fill it up. So yeah, that combustion time is just a reflection of the amount of things which can catch fire, which has increased significantly. I want to play your clip from the comedian George Carlin, who had a joke about the real purpose of all our homes.
车都停在人行道上。人们实际上是把一个房间塞满了，然后不得不把东西放进车库填满。所以，燃烧时间只是反映了可燃物品的数量，而这个数量已经显著增加了。我想播放一段喜剧演员乔治·卡林的片段，他讲了一个关于我们所有家庭真正用途的笑话。
That's the whole meaning of life is in a trying to find a place for your stuff. That's all your houses. Your house is just a place for your stuff. If you didn't have so much goddamn stuff, you wouldn't need a house. You could just walk around all the time. That's all your houses. It's a pile of stuff with a cover on it. You see that when you take off in an airplane and you look down and you see everybody's got a little pile of stuff. Everybody's got their little pile of stuff. Everybody's got their own pile of stuff. And when you look down and you see everybody's got a little pile of stuff. I remember a time in my life when I felt like all my worldly possessions not only fit in
这就是生命的全部意义，试图为你的东西找个地方。这就是你们所有的房子。你的房子只是你东西的存放处。如果你没有那么多该死的东西，你就不需要房子了。你可以一直走来走去。这就是你们所有的房子。它只是一堆盖着盖子的东西。当你坐飞机起飞往下看时，你会看到每个人都有一小堆东西。每个人都有他们的一小堆东西。每个人都有他们自己的一堆东西。当你往下看，看到每个人都有一小堆东西时。我记得我生命中有一段时间，我觉得我所有的财产不仅能装进
a single room, but they fit comfortably inside a single room. When I look around my home today, if I put all my stuff in one room, I probably wouldn't be able to breathe. Is that the same for you, Bruce? Oh, yeah, I mean, we generally up size our houses when we get kids, especially when you I probably wouldn't be able to breathe. Is that the same for you, Bruce? Yeah, it is. I mean, we generally up size our houses when we get kids, especially when you get children. You suddenly find yourself buying a whole lot of things
一个房间，而且能舒适地装进一个房间。今天当我环顾我的家时，如果我把所有的东西都放进一个房间，我可能连呼吸都困难。布鲁斯，你也是这样吗？哦，是的，我的意思是，我们通常在有了孩子后会换更大的房子，特别是当你……我可能连呼吸都困难。布鲁斯，你也是这样吗？是的，确实如此。我的意思是，我们通常在有了孩子后会换更大的房子，特别是当你有了孩子之后。你突然发现自己买了很多
that you never knew existed. As we go through different stages of life, we just seem to accumulate more and more. And getting rid of it is really a bit of a challenge as something I've found very difficult. Although I think in the States, you guys often got yard sales. So maybe it's a cultural thing with a bit of variation. But yeah, invariably you accumulate more and more things.
你以前根本不知道存在的东西。随着我们经历人生的不同阶段，我们似乎只是在不断积累。而摆脱它们确实是一个挑战，我发现这非常困难。虽然我认为在美国，你们经常有庭院旧货出售。所以这可能是一种带有细微差别的文化现象。但无论如何，你总是会积累越来越多的东西。
Yeah, although the yard sales are a way of transferring the junk inside your home to the... Just right, basically by someone else's junk. Yeah, we should just keep our own junk and then on bottom of the art sale, you're absolutely right. I want to get to our propensity to own stuff, the psychology of it, but I want to start with a simpler idea that you alluded to actually a second ago. 200 years ago, people owned a lot less stuff than we do today.
是的，虽然庭院旧货出售是一种把你家里的垃圾转移到……没错，基本上就是买别人的垃圾。是的，我们应该只保留自己的垃圾，然后在庭院旧货出售时卖掉，你是完全正确的。我想谈谈我们拥有东西的倾向，也就是它的心理学，但我先从一个更简单的想法开始，你刚才其实已经提到了。200年前，人们拥有的东西比我们今天少得多。
What is the role of the industrial revolution in producing all the stuff that we see in our lives today? It's really interesting when you think about the amount of time it would have taken to make a very common household item, say a chair, for example. I mean, there would have been skilled craftsmen who would turn the lace and make the wood and glue it together. And it could have taken them quite a bit of time to do that. But when we developed the industrial revolution, we had machinery, we had lathes that were driven by water wheels initially, then we had steam powered machinery. And so one person, rather than taking a day, could start to produce literally tens of chairs
工业革命在生产我们今天生活中所见的所有东西方面扮演了什么角色？当你想到制造一件非常普通的家居用品（比如一把椅子）所需要的时间时，这真的很有趣。我的意思是，会有熟练的工匠来车削木头、制作木材并将其粘合在一起。这可能需要他们相当长的时间。但当我们发展了工业革命，我们有了机械，我们有了最初由水轮驱动的车床，然后我们有了蒸汽动力机械。所以一个人，不再需要一天的时间，就可以开始生产出几十把椅子，
and then eventually hundreds of chairs with mechanization. And so what happened was this exponential rise in productivity. People migrated from the countryside into the cities to fill the factories, and the factories started to generate more and more products. And of course the profit margin lines started to decrease, so they had to sell more and more things. So what I think was a perfect storm, if you like, of the ability to produce more stuff, but also at the same time, people who are really working upon our psychology to make us want
最终通过机械化生产出数百把椅子。于是发生的事情就是生产力的指数级增长。人们从农村迁移到城市进入工厂，工厂开始生产越来越多的产品。当然，利润率开始下降，所以他们不得不卖出越来越多的东西。所以我认为这是一场完美的风暴，如果你愿意的话，既有生产更多东西的能力，同时也有一群人真正在操纵我们的心理，让我们想要
to buy more and more things. So as you just indicated, the Industrial Revolution produced a lot of stuff, and marketers have gotten very skilled at selling the stuff to us. So as you just indicated, the Industrial Revolution produced a lot of stuff and marketers have gotten very skilled at selling the stuff to us, but they didn't actually produce the desires that we have in the first place. In your book, you tell the Ewaqadah story of the sinking of a ship called the Royal Charter in 1859. It was returning to Liverpool from Australia. Tell me what happened on the ship, Bruce? Yeah, this was a remarkable story, as you say. It was a ship returning from the gold fields of Australia. It sank off the coast of North of Wales just on its return to Liverpool.
购买越来越多的东西。正如你刚才指出的，工业革命生产了大量的东西，而营销人员已经变得非常擅长向我们推销这些东西。正如你刚才指出的，工业革命生产了大量的东西，营销人员已经变得非常擅长向我们推销这些东西，但他们并没有从一开始就制造出我们内心的欲望。在你的书中，你讲述了1859年“皇家宪章号”沉船的悲惨故事。它当时正从澳大利亚返回利物浦。布鲁斯，告诉我船上发生了什么？是的，正如你所说，这是一个非凡的故事。那是一艘从澳大利亚金矿返回的船。它在返回利物浦的途中在北威尔士海岸沉没。
But what makes the story more tragic in many ways is that this was not inevitable because many of the people who drowned were the miners who wouldn't relinquish the gold that they had so furiously worked for. They had it sown into their coats and they wore money belts and they wouldn't abandon it and unfortunately the extra weight just pulled them to their death. So I think that story just reveals that we can become very irrational when it comes to giving up our possessions. In this case gold is notoriously turns your men into fools. Our insatiable hunger to own things remains ever present today. And increasingly, as more of our lives are spent online,
但让这个故事在许多方面更显悲剧色彩的是，这并非不可避免，因为许多溺水的人是那些不愿放弃他们辛苦挖掘出的黄金的矿工。他们把黄金缝在外套里，戴着钱带，他们不愿放弃，不幸的是，额外的重量把他们拖向了死亡。所以我认为这个故事揭示了我们在放弃财产时会变得非常不理性。在这种情况下，黄金众所周知会让人变得愚蠢。我们对拥有东西的贪婪欲望在今天依然存在。而且，随着我们越来越多的生活在网上度过，
the possessions that we desire don't even need to be tangible items. Bruce cites an unusual club that sold in 2010 for $635,000. It was called Club Never Die. Well, this is a remarkable story which really reveals the way that our attitudes to possessions don't necessarily have to be physical possessions. They can be concepts. They can be thoughts. They can be ideas. And I'm talking about the world of online gaming. And Club Never Die was a virtual club where you could buy virtual items. To be more precise, it was a virtual club on a virtual asteroid in a virtual universe. People were really immersed in this whole gaming world. But effectively, they were paying good money for virtual objects.
我们渴望的财产甚至不需要是实物。布鲁斯提到了一个在2010年以63.5万美元售出的不寻常的俱乐部。它被称为“永不消亡俱乐部”（Club Never Die）。嗯，这是一个非凡的故事，它真正揭示了我们对财产的态度不一定非要是实物财产。它们可以是概念、思想或想法。我指的是网络游戏世界。“永不消亡俱乐部”是一个虚拟俱乐部，你可以在那里购买虚拟物品。更准确地说，它是一个虚拟宇宙中一颗虚拟小行星上的虚拟俱乐部。人们真正沉浸在这个游戏世界中。但实际上，他们是在为虚拟物品支付真金白银。
But if you think about that's what a lot of gaming does. You buy icons, you buy tools, you buy things to progress in the game. So it's not entirely crazy. If you see it from a gamer's perspective, but what makes it bizarre, I suppose, if you didn't understand the rules of the game, is that literally people are paying for things which are totally intangible. Human beings have a seemingly endless desire to acquire things. When we come back, why we want so much stuff and how our possessions get intertwined with our identities.
但如果你想想，这就是很多游戏所做的事情。你购买图标、工具，购买在游戏中进步的东西。所以这并不完全疯狂。如果你从玩家的角度来看，但我想如果你不了解游戏规则，这看起来就很离奇，因为人们确实是在为完全无形的东西付费。人类似乎有着无止境的获取欲望。当我们回来时，我们将探讨为什么我们想要这么多东西，以及我们的财产是如何与我们的身份交织在一起的。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Bruce Heard is a psychologist at the University of Bristol. Like other social observers, he's noticed that many of us own much more stuff than we need. Bruce has also discovered that in a very real sense, it is not just we who own our possessions. Our possessions also own us. Bruce has observed this in his own relationship to things, particularly when it comes to his love affair with horror movies and memorabilia associated with them. One of his favourites is an obscure film called Night or the Demon. in a world of darkness. And it is also said,
你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。布鲁斯·胡德是布里斯托大学的心理学家。和其他社会观察家一样，他注意到我们许多人拥有的东西远超我们的需求。布鲁斯还发现，从某种非常真实的意义上说，不仅仅是我们拥有财产，我们的财产也在拥有我们。布鲁斯在自己与物品的关系中观察到了这一点，特别是在他对比恐怖电影及其相关纪念品的热爱上。他最喜欢的电影之一是一部鲜为人知的电影，叫《恶魔之夜》（Night of the Demon）。在黑暗的世界里。而且据说，
man can call forth these powers of darkness, the demons of hell. I actually do own the original poster, and I spend a lot of money on it. I've got maybe 60 odd movie posters from that era. That one is the one I like the most. What's strange about that era, that one is the one I like the most. What's strange about that is, you know, I'm a psychologist, I'm a scientist, and I should be rational and reasonable.
人可以召唤这些黑暗的力量，地狱的恶魔。我确实拥有那张原版海报，我花了很多钱买它。我大概有60多张那个时代的海报。那一张是我最喜欢的。关于那个时代，奇怪的是，那一张是我最喜欢的。奇怪的是，你知道，我是一名心理学家，一名科学家，我本应该是理性和理智的。
But you know, when I start to realize I could acquire and own posters from that genre, you could buy them on eBay, I went through a period of obsessive collecting because I got them to these online auctions and then there were other horror posters on there. And I discovered that I'm not as rational as I think I am because I found myself bidding on these online auctions for things that really, I didn't have the space to show because these are big posters, you know,
但你知道，当我开始意识到我可以获取并拥有那个类型的海报时，你可以在eBay上买到它们，我经历了一段强迫性收集的时期，因为我进入了这些在线拍卖，然后上面还有其他恐怖海报。我发现我并不像我想象的那么理性，因为我发现自己在这些在线拍卖中竞拍那些我根本没有空间展示的东西，因为这些海报很大，你知道，
these are about a meter by, a meter and a half. They're very large. And I don't have a house that big, I could even display them, but I kept buying things. And it was partly the thrill of the chase I realized that actually it wasn't so much the acquisition of the poster It was more the chase of getting it and that's what really drove me on and this has been born out by the science This is one the reasons we buy things is it's not so much to actually have it But it's the pursuit of it which is so thrilling
它们大约有一米乘一米半。它们非常大。我没有那么大的房子，甚至无法展示它们，但我还是不停地买。我意识到，这在一定程度上是追求的快感，实际上与其说是为了获得海报，不如说是为了获得它的过程，这才是真正驱动我的原因。这一点已经被科学所证实。我们购买东西的原因之一，与其说是为了真正拥有它，不如说是追求它的过程非常令人兴奋。
Where have you stored these posters in your home? Well, I have put up as many as I possibly can on the wall, much to my wife's dismay, but most of them I'm afraid are disfolded away carefully and kept in storage until I sort of build up the courage to sell them. But there again, I'm succumbing to my irrational behavior about not wanting to let anything go. Speaking of not letting anything go, Bruce, your wife inherited several things from her parents
你把这些海报存放在家里的什么地方？嗯，我尽可能多地把它们挂在墙上，这让我妻子非常沮丧，但我恐怕大部分都被小心地折叠起来，存放在储藏室里，直到我鼓起勇气把它们卖掉。但在这里，我又屈服于我不愿放手的非理性行为了。说到不愿放手，布鲁斯，你妻子从她父母那里继承了一些东西
after they passed away. What were these items and what did you do with them? We've actually just had this conversation about what are we gonna do with all the stuff in the attic? And I'm sure many of your listeners will have had the exacty this experience that, you lose a pair, you lose a loved one, and then you inherit all their household items. And as a child, getting rid of your parents' stuff can be emotionally very difficult to do. So we've ended up holding onto this. This
在他们去世后。这些是什么物品，你对它们做了什么？我们实际上刚刚讨论过我们要怎么处理阁楼里的所有东西。我相信你们的许多听众都有过完全相同的经历：你失去了一位亲人，然后继承了他们所有的家居用品。作为一个孩子，处理父母的东西在情感上是非常困难的。所以我们最终还是留下了这些。这
is now, I must say, it's now 20 years. We've still got this attic full of her parents' household possessions. And this is real sentimental value. You just don't want to violate. Do you know what kind of items these are? It's just one of the things at the time you kind of recognize that your parents valued it. But in today's comparison, it's things
现在，我必须说，已经20年了。我们仍然留着那个装满她父母家居用品的阁楼。这确实有情感价值。你只是不想破坏它。你知道这些是什么样的物品吗？这只是当时你意识到你父母很看重的东西，但在今天的比较中，它们是
which are just kind of rather useless. But literally all the household items, certainly a lot of the furniture. There's a lot of crockery. All the knickknacks made out of glass and stuff that used to sit on mantle pieces, but you never dream of buying yourself, but because it comes from a relation, then that has this deeper emotional connection. So one of the central contentions you have is that possessions become markers of identity for people. So for your wife to take her parents things and put them in the trash would be at least in a metaphorical sense, you know, like taking her parents and putting them in the trash,
相当无用的东西。但确实是所有的家居用品，当然还有很多家具。有很多陶器。所有那些曾经放在壁炉架上的玻璃小摆设之类的东西，你永远不会梦想自己去买，但因为它们来自亲戚，所以它们就有了更深的情感联系。所以你的核心观点之一是，财产成为了人们身份的标志。所以对于你妻子来说，把她父母的东西拿走扔进垃圾桶，至少在隐喻意义上，就像是把她的父母扔进垃圾桶一样，
it would be unthinkable. Yeah, in our work, we've kind of really, you know, drilled down deeply into this. I think for some people, not everyone, there's a deeper sense that there's some physical presence still in the object, and that's what I've been fascinated with. I want to get under the hood of our appetite to own things, and perhaps start all the way back in childhood. This is of course core to your own research interests. What is studies of early childhood reveal about the nature
那将是不可想象的。是的，在我们的工作中，我们已经深入研究了这一点。我认为对一些人来说，而不是所有人，有一种更深层的感觉，即物体中仍然存在某种物理存在，这就是我一直着迷的地方。我想深入了解我们拥有东西的欲望，也许从童年开始。这当然是你自己研究兴趣的核心。关于我们拥有东西的欲望的本质，早期童年的研究揭示了什么？
of our desire to possess things? Yes, so again this was this came from a personal experience. My daughter, my eldest daughter, formed a very strong emotional attachment to a blanket and very young babies will form emotional attachments to teddy bears and blankets. But as children grew up, a lot of them don't abandon it. By the way, my daughter is now 26 and she still has her blanket. And this is a guilty secret I discovered in many of my students when I asked them did they have these childhood items.
是的，这同样来自个人经历。我的女儿，我的大女儿，对一条毯子产生了非常强烈的情感依恋，非常年幼的婴儿会对泰迪熊和毯子产生情感依恋。但随着孩子长大，很多人并没有放弃它。顺便说一句，我女儿现在26岁了，她仍然留着她的毯子。当我问我的学生他们是否有这些童年物品时，我发现这是一个公开的秘密。
And for a large number of people in the West, they formed strong emotional attachments to these possessions. And that made me realize that items and objects of ownership can form a very deep seated connection with the identity. Children fall in love with their teddy bears, blankets, and dolls, and these objects can become almost as real to them as living creatures. Bruce was once contacted by someone who told him a story of how his mother refused to part with one of these attachment objects during the German bombing of London during World War II.
对于西方的大量人群来说，他们对这些财产产生了强烈的情感依恋。这让我意识到，所有权的物品和对象可以与身份形成一种根深蒂固的联系。孩子们爱上了他们的泰迪熊、毯子和玩偶，这些物体对他们来说几乎变得和活的生物一样真实。布鲁斯曾经被一个人联系过，那个人告诉他一个故事，说他的母亲在二战期间德国轰炸伦敦时，拒绝放弃这些依恋对象中的一个。
He contacted me, he said that his 87-year-old mother had to be restrained when she was in the Blitz in London and they went down into the underground to avoid the bombs, but she'd left her blanket back in the house and she had to be physically restrained from going out to try and retrieve it, such as the power of these things that people have this really emotional connection to these childhood sentimental objects. So I think that's hardly fascinating, it just strikes me as really an unusual human behavior. Now, I used to think it was uniquely human. I ran a study about a year or two ago looking at dogs
他联系了我，他说他87岁的母亲在伦敦大轰炸期间不得不被约束，当时他们为了躲避炸弹进入了地铁，但她把毯子留在了房子里，她不得不被强行阻止回去取回它，这就是人们对这些童年情感物品所拥有的强烈情感联系的力量。所以我认为这非常迷人，这让我觉得这是一种非常不寻常的人类行为。以前我以为这是人类独有的。我一两年前做了一项研究，观察狗，
and discovered that some breeds of dogs also form strong emotional attachments to certain toys. So it's not unique to humans. You find it in some domesticated pets. And I think that's fascinating. The psychologist Lita Furby has found a link between possessions and a feeling of control. This is not just with possessions that we have a deep attachment for, but even just everyday possessions.
发现某些品种的狗也会对特定的玩具产生强烈的情感依恋。所以这并不是人类独有的。你在一些家养宠物身上也能发现这一点。我认为这很迷人。心理学家丽塔·弗比发现财产与控制感之间存在联系。这不仅限于我们有深厚依恋的财产，甚至包括日常财产。
Can you talk about this relationship that the things we own also gave us a sense of control in the world? Interesting enough, I think that's actually how the concept of ownership really starts to develop in children because initially they don't really have a concept of ownership really starts to develop in children because initially they don't really have a concept of ownership, they'll help themselves to everything and that's why you got to tell very young children to put that down, that doesn't belong to you, that's your brothers or so on. With time, they begin to understand that other people can own things, but their concept of
你能谈谈这种关系吗？即我们拥有的东西也给了我们一种对世界的控制感？有趣的是，我认为这实际上就是所有权概念在儿童身上开始发展的方式，因为最初他们并没有真正拥有所有权的概念，他们会随意拿走所有东西，这就是为什么你必须告诉非常年幼的孩子放下那个，那不属于你，那是你哥哥的等等。随着时间的推移，他们开始理解其他人也可以拥有东西，但他们的所有权概念
ownership is very much based on who controls it. So if they can't control it, then they don't own it. And that's why, for example, at five years of age, children think that someone who's asleep or in a coma can't own something because they can't act upon it. They can't control it. So I think the concept of ownership really emerges from this physical possession of something and the ability to exert control over it.
很大程度上是基于谁控制它。所以如果他们不能控制它，那么他们就不拥有它。这就是为什么，例如，五岁的孩子认为睡着或昏迷的人不能拥有东西，因为他们无法对其采取行动。他们无法控制它。所以我认为所有权的概念确实源于对某物的物理占有以及施加控制的能力。
And if you can do that, you can own it. And that's one of the reasons I think that children fight so much over possessions. And it's partly to do with taking control of it. It's also they recognize that whoever has control has status. And so they understand there's a relationship between the more that you can control and the more status you have. So many of us think that we want things and then we go and acquire them, and of course, that's true, but psychological studies also reveal that the arrow of causation can sometimes
如果你能做到这一点，你就能拥有它。我认为这是孩子们为财产争吵如此之多的原因之一。这在一定程度上与夺取控制权有关。他们也认识到，谁拥有控制权，谁就拥有地位。所以他们明白，你控制得越多，你的地位就越高，这两者之间存在联系。所以我们许多人认为我们想要东西，然后我们就去获取它们，当然，这是事实，但心理学研究也揭示了因果关系的箭头有时
run in the other direction, acquiring things can increase our desire and appetite for them. Tell me about a phenomenon that you study that's called the endowment effect. People want us to evaluate the value of, or the worth of something, say for example, a coffee cup. They'll give a reasonably objective value, but as soon as I take possession of it, that value increases. And this is called the endowment effect. People value their own possessions, more than others are willing to pay for them. It generally doesn't appear in children probably until around about six years of age, but we did some studies showing you could induce the endowment effect in much younger children simply by getting them to think about themselves and their possessions as an extension of themselves. And when you're primed to think about yourself, you suddenly become very aware of all your
会向相反方向运行，获取东西可以增加我们对它们的欲望和胃口。告诉我一个你研究的现象，叫做“禀赋效应”。人们想要我们评估某样东西的价值，比如一个咖啡杯。他们会给出一个相当客观的价值，但一旦我拥有了它，那个价值就会增加。这就是所谓的“禀赋效应”。人们对自己财产的评价高于他人愿意为之支付的价格。它通常在儿童身上直到六岁左右才会出现，但我们做了一些研究表明，你可以通过让他们思考自己和他们的财产是他们自身的一部分，从而在更小的孩子身上诱发禀赋效应。当你被引导去思考你自己时，你突然变得非常意识到你所有的
possessions and you think, oh, the worth more. So it's a kind of interesting kind of extension of our identity extension of the self. Yeah, and it's interesting when a car salesman is trying to sell a vehicle to you. One of the things they do at least in the United States is ask you to take it for a test drive or it's always even keep it for a couple of days. And again, the sense is that once you feel like the vehicle is an extension of you that you belong in the vehicle and the vehicle belongs in your life, you become much more likely to become a customer. That's right.
财产，你会想，哦，它们更值钱。所以这是一种有趣的身份延伸，自我的延伸。是的，当汽车推销员试图向你推销车辆时，这很有趣。在美国，他们至少会做的一件事是让你去试驾，或者甚至让你保留几天。同样，这种感觉是，一旦你觉得这辆车是你的一部分，你属于这辆车，而这辆车属于你的生活，你就更有可能成为客户。没错。
It's a well-known technique in salespeople that you know, to try something on just to touch it. As soon as you touch or feel it, then that sense of endowment is triggered and you can just see yourself owning it. So we've looked at different ways. Our identity is get wrapped up in the things that we own. And once your identity gets wrapped up in a possession, it starts to make sense why we are so reluctant to let our stuff go and perhaps even why we store so much stuff as we discuss to the top of this conversation, letting go of our possessions can feel like letting
这是推销员中一种众所周知的技巧，你知道，试穿一下，只是摸摸它。一旦你触摸或感觉到它，那种禀赋感就会被触发，你就能看到自己拥有它的样子。所以我们研究了不同的方式。我们的身份被包裹在我们拥有的东西中。一旦你的身份被包裹在一种财产中，为什么我们如此不愿放手，甚至为什么我们存储这么多东西（正如我们在对话开头讨论的那样）就说得通了，放弃我们的财产感觉就像放弃
go of parts of ourselves. Yeah, I think that's absolutely true. And I think that this is something that can be amplified by context. So if we're in around others who are signaling their identity through their possessions, we might be filled some compulsion or some urge to compete with them. And so it really does, I think, mirror the circumstances we find ourselves in. And that's why I think the cultural context can be so important. So, for example, sharing behaviour is entirely culturally determined. Children sort of fairly selfish, despite what we're
我们自身的一部分。是的，我认为这是绝对正确的。而且我认为这可以通过环境来放大。所以如果我们周围的人通过他们的财产来展示他们的身份，我们可能会感到某种强迫或某种竞争的冲动。所以我认为这确实反映了我们所处的环境。这就是为什么我认为文化背景如此重要。例如，分享行为完全是由文化决定的。孩子们相当自私，尽管我们
likely to believe, any parent will tell you this. And they have to learn that sharing is the social norm, but that norm depends on the culture you're raised in. And that's why studying children, you really need to look at what their parents are modeling towards them as what's appropriate behavior. You're used the word signaling a second ago in the conversation. And I wonder if we can talk about that for a moment. Sometimes our possessions are not just you know, extensions of our identity, but they're badges, if you will, that allow us to signal things And I wonder if we can talk about that for a moment. Sometimes our possessions are not just extensions of our identity, but they're badges, if you will, that allow us to signal things to other people.
可能愿意相信，任何父母都会告诉你这一点。他们必须学习分享是社会规范，但这种规范取决于你成长的文化。这就是为什么研究儿童时，你真的需要看看他们的父母在向他们展示什么是适当的行为。你刚才在对话中用了“信号”这个词。我想我们可以谈谈那个。有时我们的财产不仅仅是身份的延伸，它们是徽章，如果你愿意的话，允许我们向其他人发出信号。
Can you talk about this role that possessions play in our lives? Sure. So signaling theory really is one branch of evolutionary or sexual selection theories. It goes back to Darwin. And one of the things that when Darwin was putting together the theory of natural selection, he was very confused
你能谈谈财产在我们生活中扮演的这个角色吗？当然。所以信号理论确实是进化论或性选择理论的一个分支。它追溯到达尔文。当达尔文在整理自然选择理论时，他非常困惑
about why certain animals would evolve really ridiculous kind of displays of color and plumage. And in particular, he identified the peacock. The male peacock has this elaborate tale as everyone knows. It's a beautiful thing. But from a selection point of view,
为什么某些动物会进化出非常荒谬的颜色和羽毛展示。特别是，他确定了孔雀。正如每个人所知，雄孔雀有这种精致的尾巴。这是一件美丽的事情。但从选择的角度来看，
it's really quite cumbersome and requires a lot of energy to build and it makes the bird flightless. So why would it evolve such a ridiculous adaptation? Well, then Darwin figured out a second component of evolution, which is sexual selection. So not only is nature selecting you in natural selection, but you're competing against other mates, you're competing against other animals. And that's the reason that
它确实相当笨重，需要大量的能量来构建，而且它使鸟类无法飞行。那么为什么它会进化出如此荒谬的适应性呢？嗯，达尔文发现了进化的第二个组成部分，即性选择。所以自然选择不仅在自然选择中选择你，而且你还在与其他配偶竞争，你还在与其他动物竞争。这就是为什么
in the animal kingdom, typically the male is most colorful compared to the female. If you look at birds, for example, it's invariably true that the male of the species is much more colorful and the reason is more colorful is it's signaling its prowess to potential females because the females because they only have one egg, they get to be choosy. In humans, of course, we also signal our prowess or signal our states by the possessions that we can claim ownership over, which in many ways are proxy of our genetic fitness in terms of enabling the rights or resources that could be passed on to any potential offspring. Bruce is not the first researcher to draw this link between the flashiness of a peacock's tail
在动物王国中，通常雄性比雌性更丰富多彩。如果你看鸟类，例如，雄性物种比雌性丰富多彩是必然的，原因是因为它更丰富多彩，它是在向潜在的雌性发出其能力的信号，因为雌性因为它们只有一个卵子，所以它们可以挑剔。当然，在人类中，我们也通过我们可以声称拥有所有权的财产来发出我们能力的信号或发出我们状态的信号，这在许多方面是我们遗传适应性的代理，能够实现可以传递给任何潜在后代的权利或资源。布鲁斯并不是第一个在孔雀尾巴的华丽与人类文化中玛莎拉蒂或名牌手袋的华丽之间建立这种联系的研究人员。
and the flashiness in human culture of a Maserati or a designer handbag. It's precisely because luxury objects are unnecessary that they can become potent signals of status. In other words, they become what sociologists call conspicuous consumption. Porsenveblen sociologists point out that people would spend money, good money on items which were of no additional value. They would prefer to spend more for silver spoon than a puter spoon, as you famously
正是因为奢侈品是不必要的，它们才能成为地位的有力信号。换句话说，它们成为了社会学家所说的“炫耀性消费”。社会学家凡勃伦指出，人们会花钱，花好钱在没有额外价值的物品上。正如你著名地
said. And the reason is, is not because it's a better spoon, but it's a way of showing off to other people that you have the disposable income, you can afford it. One of the motivations for owning certain items is they're not necessarily that much better, but they signal to other people what our status is. So that's one of the mechanisms for this ownership, this conspicuous consumption. I mean, you say that the global luxury market is worth $1.2 trillion. I mean, that's a lot of peacock tails right there. That's a lot of peacock tails. There's a lot of conspicuous consumption going on there. But the thing is, of course, it does also ring true that when people put on luxury
所说，他们宁愿花更多的钱买银勺而不是锡勺。原因不是因为它是一把更好的勺子，而是向其他人炫耀你有可支配收入，你买得起它的一种方式。拥有某些物品的动机之一是它们不一定好得多，但它们向其他人发出了我们的地位信号。所以这是这种所有权、这种炫耀性消费的机制之一。我的意思是，你说全球奢侈品市场价值1.2万亿美元。我的意思是，那里面有很多孔雀尾巴。那里面有很多炫耀性消费。但当然，当人们穿上奢侈品
goods or feel that they're wearing something of which makes them special, they behave differently as well. So there's a kind of feedback mechanism on our psyche. There was one experiment I understand where volunteers were given golf clubs that had been owned by the US golfing champion Ben Curtis. Biggest part of his life right now. in golf clubs that had been owned by the US golfing champion Ben Curtis. And I understand that when they used these golf clubs, they actually performed better at golf. It's good. Yes!
商品或觉得他们穿着让他们变得特别的东西时，他们的行为也会有所不同。所以我们的心理有一种反馈机制。我了解到有一个实验，志愿者被给予了由美国高尔夫冠军本·柯蒂斯拥有的高尔夫球杆。他生命中最重要的部分。由美国高尔夫冠军本·柯蒂斯拥有的高尔夫球杆。我了解到，当他们使用这些高尔夫球杆时，他们在高尔夫球上的表现实际上更好。很好。是的！
Big Ben! It is indeed, that's absolutely true, so it was an experiment where they were told the club belonged to the famous golfer. In fact, it didn't, but the belief gave them the confidence to actually perceive the whole to be larger for some reason and their efforts were much more accurate. So again, it comes back to this idea that even though this is a rational behavior, it can actually have tangible rational benefits because people think it's actually given them an advantage. And also, the fact that owned by a famous person also introduces the idea of scarcity, right?
大本！确实如此，这绝对是真的，所以这是一个实验，他们被告知球杆属于那位著名的高尔夫球手。事实上，它并没有，但这种信念给了他们信心，让他们实际上因为某种原因感知到整个球洞更大，他们的努力也更准确。所以，这又回到了这个想法，即尽管这是一种非理性的行为，但它实际上可以产生有形的理性利益，因为人们认为它实际上给了他们优势。而且，由名人拥有也引入了稀缺性的概念，对吧？
So in other words, if you have Ben Curtis's clubs, then by definition, there only a few of them. If a product is widely available and you can be easily duplicated, in some ways it loses its power as a signaling device because part of what makes a luxury item or luxury item is not just that you have it, but that other people don't have it.
换句话说，如果你有本·柯蒂斯的球杆，那么根据定义，它们只有少数几套。如果一种产品广泛可用并且可以很容易地复制，在某种程度上它作为信号设备就失去了力量，因为奢侈品之所以成为奢侈品，部分原因不仅在于你拥有它，还在于其他人没有它。
Yeah, so I think that's indeed true, but I would also say that I still feel that it's the physical connection is what people value because you get the opposite effect from things which have been owned by people who are reviled like murderous. Bruce has tested this idea before a live audience. Do people really imbue objects owned by murderers with a negative psychological essence? I have here. It's a beautiful Kashmir cardigan. Now it's been washed.
是的，所以我认为这确实是真的，但我也会说，我仍然觉得人们看重的是物理联系，因为你从那些被像杀人犯这样的人所厌恶的人拥有的东西中得到了相反的效果。布鲁斯在现场观众面前测试过这个想法。人们真的会给杀人犯拥有的物体注入负面的心理本质吗？我这里有。这是一件漂亮的羊绒开衫。现在它已经被洗过了。
And it was owned by a very famous individual. How many of you would be willing to put the cardigan on for, say, 20 pounds? Put your hands up if you'd be willing to do so. That's excellent. Now, keep your hands up. If you would still wear the cardigan, if you were to discover that the owner was none other
它是由一个非常著名的人拥有的。你们中有多少人愿意花，比如说20英镑穿上这件开衫？如果愿意，请举手。太棒了。现在，保持举手。如果你发现主人不是别人，
than the serial mass murderer, Fred West. OK, now there's always a couple who resolutely keep their hands up. You might want to look at the people around you who are now regarding you with some degree of suspicion. And it's just the prospect of coming into physical contact is something that really makes people feel emotional about it. So it works both for the positive things owned by celebrities but also the negative revulsion that we feel by things which are being known previously by people who are evil.
而是连环杀手弗雷德·韦斯特，你还会穿这件开衫吗？好的，总有几个人坚定地举着手。你们可能想看看周围那些现在正以某种怀疑眼光看着你们的人。仅仅是与它发生身体接触的前景，就真的让人们对此感到情绪化。所以它既适用于名人拥有的积极事物，也适用于我们对那些以前被邪恶的人所拥有的东西感到的负面厌恶。
And that tells me that this is a mechanism which probably ties into a sense of biological contamination, is if there's some sort of, I think the word is, kouties in America, there's something you can catch. And that's somehow imbued in the clothing. I was talking some time ago with the researcher Ann Bowers. She once measured how much people on the hunt for wedding rings would pay for used rings, but there was a catch. Some of the rings were said to have come from happily married people and some were said to have come from divorced people.
这告诉我，这是一种可能与生物污染感联系在一起的机制，就像在美国有一种词叫“细菌”（kouties），有些东西你可以传染。而这不知何故被注入到了衣服里。我前段时间和研究员安·鲍尔斯谈过。她曾经测量过寻找结婚戒指的人愿意为二手戒指支付多少钱，但有一个陷阱。有些戒指据说来自幸福的已婚人士，有些据说来自离婚人士。
So on average, people priced the divorce ring at about $550 and they price the happy marriage ring at about $780 and it's funny I asked people in the experiment you know why did you price the way that you priced and people would say things like I know I shouldn't believe this I know it's just a ring but it doesn't matter I wouldn't be okay with this it just feels wrong and they can't really articulate why because they do know it's just a ring but it doesn't matter, I wouldn't be okay with this, it just feels wrong. And they can't really articulate why because they do know it's just a piece of metal but it becomes really important in these settings. What's fascinating to me Bruce is that you have simultaneously these two things happening which is you recognize that the belief is irrational but the belief still has power
所以平均而言，人们给离婚戒指定价约为550美元，给幸福婚姻戒指定价约为780美元，有趣的是，我在实验中问人们，你知道为什么你这样定价，人们会说诸如“我知道我不应该相信这个，我知道这只是一个戒指，但这没关系，我不会接受这个，它感觉就是不对”之类的话。他们无法真正表达原因，因为他们确实知道这只是一个戒指，但这没关系，我不会接受这个，它感觉就是不对。他们无法真正表达原因，因为他们确实知道这只是一块金属，但在这些环境中它变得非常重要。布鲁斯，让我着迷的是，你同时发生了这两件事，即你认识到这种信念是非理性的，但这种信念仍然具有力量。
over you. Yeah and I think the reason is is because we all start off developing irrational beliefs as young children, but as you grow up, you learn through science education that these things are irrational, but you can't eradicate these primitive beliefs. They're always there, and that's why they can come out at times of stress, which is suddenly fun yourself behaving irrationally, and that's because they never go away. You know, we've talked a little bit about conspicuous consumption and how people use luxury objects to signal things to other people, but researchers in recent years have also explored
你。是的，我认为原因在于我们所有人从小就开始形成非理性的信念，但随着成长，你通过科学教育了解到这些东西是不合理的，但你无法根除这些原始的信念。它们一直都在，这就是为什么它们会在压力时刻显现出来，让你突然发现自己表现得不理智，那是因为它们从未消失。你知道，我们之前谈到过炫耀性消费，以及人们如何利用奢侈品向他人传递信号，但近年来研究人员也探索了
the idea of inconspicuous consumption. Can you talk about this idea that in some ways, perhaps because luxury goods have become so widely available and because so many people now actually have luxury goods, you can no longer compete with your neighbor by buying a fancy car because your neighbor also has a fancy car. And so you come up with new ways to compete using what people call inconspicuous consumption. What are these? Well, these are codes. For example, dressing down is something that you sometimes see in that very wealthy, especially,
非炫耀性消费的概念。你能谈谈这个观点吗？在某些方面，也许是因为奢侈品变得如此普及，而且现在很多人实际上都拥有奢侈品，你不能再通过买一辆豪车来与邻居竞争，因为你的邻居也有一辆豪车。于是，你开始想出新的竞争方式，使用人们所说的非炫耀性消费。这些是什么？嗯，这些是某种准则。例如，穿着朴素是你有时在非常富有的人身上看到的，尤其是，
it's almost become almost a bit of a uniform for Silicon Valley that they don't wear a suit and tie. And again, dressing down in when you're in a position of power is sort of counter-signalling, saying, look, I don't need to show off because I'm so wealthy. Whether we're aware of it or not, we're adopting uniforms, we're using these artifacts, we're using clothing to tell a story of what we'd like to portray to others. Some years ago, Francesca Gino at the Harvard Business School asked shopping assistants
这几乎成了硅谷的一种制服，他们不穿西装打领带。再说一次，当你处于权力地位时，穿着朴素是一种反向信号，意思是，看，我不需要炫耀，因为我非常富有。无论我们是否意识到，我们都在采用制服，我们正在使用这些人工制品，我们正在使用服装来讲述一个我们想要向他人展示的故事。几年前，哈佛商学院的弗朗西斯卡·吉诺（Francesca Gino）要求购物助理
who worked in luxury designer stores to evaluate shoppers, to tell who was likely to spend more money. And the shopping assistants believed that people who wore gym clothes in these luxury designer stores were likely to spend more money than shoppers who came in dressed formally. And this again speaks to that idea that you just talked about, the idea of counter-signally. That's right. I mean, I actually did that on Rodeo Drive. My honeymoon when my wife and I went out to California
在奢侈品店工作的店员评估顾客，判断谁更有可能花更多的钱。购物助理认为，在这些奢侈品店里穿运动服的人比穿着正式的顾客更有可能花更多的钱。这再次印证了你刚才谈到的那个观点，即反向信号的概念。没错。我的意思是，我实际上在罗迪欧大道（Rodeo Drive）上做过这件事。我和我妻子去加州度蜜月时
And we'd heard about this amazing place called Radeo Drive in Los Angeles I didn't have a lot of money at the time But we walked in some of the most exclusive stores and I was really surprised and I think it just speaks to the fact that actually they were probably aware that I must be wealthy if I walk into a store like that and dress as bad, so it can't be used in the right circumstances. For better or worse, the objects we own are deeply intertwined with our sense of who we are as people. Am I the kind of person who drives a Ferrari? Or the kind of person who has contempt for people who drive Ferrari's?
我们听说过洛杉矶那个叫罗迪欧大道的神奇地方，当时我没有多少钱，但我们走进了一些最高档的商店，我真的很惊讶，我认为这恰恰说明了他们可能意识到，如果我走进那样的商店却穿得那么糟糕，我一定很富有，所以它可以在适当的情况下使用。无论好坏，我们拥有的物品与我们对自己身份的认知深深交织在一起。我是那种开法拉利的人吗？还是那种鄙视开法拉利的人的人？
Our possessions are standings for deeper things our histories our relationships our dreams When we come back what happens when your notions of ownership? Clash with mine You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. At the University of Bristol, psychologist Bruce Hood studies how we relate to our possessions. In his book, Possessed,
我们的财产是更深层事物的代名词，我们的历史、我们的关系、我们的梦想。当我们回来时，当你的所有权观念与我的发生冲突时会发生什么？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在布里斯托尔大学，心理学家布鲁斯·胡德（Bruce Hood）研究我们如何与我们的财产建立联系。在他的书《占有》（Possessed）中，
he explains that our attachment to our stuff partly stems from the fact that our possessions are not just objects, but markers of our identity. But what this means is that the same object can mean very different things to different people. In 2007, a North Carolina man named Shannon Wiesnant bought a grill at an auction. It ended up making the local news. It all started with this innocent old smoker grill. Wiesnant bought it at an auction after the owner of one of these storage units didn't pay up on his bill.
他解释说，我们对物品的依恋部分源于这样一个事实：我们的财产不仅仅是物体，更是我们身份的标志。但这意味着同一个物体对不同的人可能意味着非常不同的事情。2007年，北卡罗来纳州一名叫香农·威斯南特（Shannon Whisnant）的男子在拍卖会上买了一个烤架。这最终上了当地新闻。这一切都始于这个无辜的旧烟熏烤架。威斯南特是在其中一个储物单元的主人没有支付账单后，在拍卖会上买下它的。
Wiesnant took his treasure home pretty quick thereafter he called 911? Why did he call 911 Bruce? Well this is one of the most strange bizarre stories that I think any of us had ever heard. He called 911 because when he opened up the grill, he found that he'd gotten more than he bargained for. Literally, he opened it up and there was a mummified left human foot inside. He got the shock of his life. He called up because he wasn't sure whether or not this was sort of a murder victim or maybe someone was
威斯南特很快就把他的宝贝带回家了，之后他打了911？布鲁斯，他为什么要打911？嗯，这是我认为我们所有人听过的最奇怪、最离奇的故事之一。他打911是因为当他打开烤架时，他发现他得到的比他预想的要多。字面上看，他打开它，里面有一只木乃伊化的左人脚。他受到了人生中最大的惊吓。他打电话是因为他不确定这是否是谋杀受害者，或者是否有人在
grave-ropping. So that's what really frightened him up. There's one problem there. I got a human foot. Have a one. About human left foot. What's your name? My name's Shannon Whistler, and it's from Matthew, got me grossed out. And the police had just mystified, so they just came and took it away. But what happened after that was really interesting, because Shannin's a bit of a character.
盗墓。所以这就是真正让他害怕的原因。有一个问题。我有一只人脚。有一只。关于左人脚。你叫什么名字？我叫香农·威斯南特，这让我感到恶心。警察也感到困惑，所以他们只是过来把它带走了。但那之后发生的事情真的很有趣，因为香农是个有个性的人。
He wanted to make a better notoriety of himself. He always aspired to being a person of note. He wanted to try and profit from it. So he realized that people had this sort of morbic curiosity with this foot. So he called the police station back, he said, I want my foot back. I own it fair and square. I go to the Bill writes, I own the smoke of grill and everything in there. And that's when the truth emerged. The foot didn't come from a corpse. This is the real kicker, as it were.
他想让自己出名。他一直渴望成为一个知名人物。他想尝试从中获利。所以他意识到人们对这只脚有一种病态的好奇心。于是他回拨了警察局，说，我想要回我的脚。我光明正大地拥有它。我买了账单，我拥有烟熏烤架和里面的一切。就在那时，真相浮出水面。这只脚不是来自尸体。这是真正的关键所在。
It came from somebody who was well-eat-true and alive, John Wood. So several years earlier, John Wood had been piloting his father's plane. The family were wealthy, they had a small light aircraft. And unfortunately, John crashed the plane. His father was killed and that was tragic. John was very seriously injured. To the extent he had to have the left foot amputated. And then for reasons which are not entirely clear, he said it was,
它来自一个身体健康且活着的人，约翰·伍德（John Wood）。几年前，约翰·伍德一直在驾驶他父亲的飞机。这个家庭很富有，他们有一架小型轻型飞机。不幸的是，约翰坠毁了飞机。他父亲遇难了，那是一场悲剧。约翰受了重伤。以至于他不得不截肢左脚。然后出于某种不完全清楚的原因，他说这是，
I think, a memorial of his father. He decided he wanted to have his foot back. So he asked the hospital and they gave him, Julie gave him his foot and he took it home and he bought some in bombing fluid and he went about bombing his foot. He put it out in the hot Carolina sun and dried it out. But he had a serious drink and drugs problem.
我想，是他父亲的纪念品。他决定要回他的脚。所以他问医院，他们给了他，正式给了他他的脚，他把它带回家，买了一些防腐液，开始给他的脚做防腐处理。他把它放在卡罗来纳炎热的阳光下晒干。但他有严重的酗酒和吸毒问题。
So he had lost all his income so he couldn't keep up the payments of rental for his house, and so he decided to put all his worldly possessions into storage. So he put the foot inside the grill, which he owned, and then put it all into the storage unit, and then moved to South Carolina. He didn't keep up with the payments on the rental for the unit. The rental company were legally entitled just to sell off all the contents. And this is how I ended up in a sale where Shannon bought the grill and to his horror discovered inside it contained this foot.
所以他失去了所有的收入，无法支付房租，于是他决定把所有的家当都存起来。所以他把脚放进他拥有的烤架里，然后把所有东西都放进储物单元，然后搬到了南卡罗来纳州。他没有继续支付单元的租金。租赁公司在法律上有权卖掉所有的内容物。这就是我最终在香农买下烤架的拍卖会上发现它的原因，他惊恐地发现里面装着这只脚。
After hearing from the police, John Wood decided he wanted his foot back. So he drove from South Carolina to North Carolina to get the foot. He was giving an interview to local TV stations in the parking lot of a dollar general store when guests who showed up. Wismont wants the foot for a tourist attraction, wood wants no part. He came to Maiden today to read a statement about the issue. To hold any personal belongings, ransom and decolled a tourist attraction without any regard to my family's grievances is despicable.
在收到警察的消息后，约翰·伍德决定要回他的脚。于是他从南卡罗来纳州开车到北卡罗来纳州去取脚。当客人出现时，他正在一家美元商店（Dollar General）的停车场接受当地电视台的采访。威斯南特想要这只脚作为旅游景点，伍德不想参与。他今天来到梅登（Maiden）宣读一份关于这个问题的声明。将任何个人物品扣为人质，并将其称为旅游景点，而不顾及我家人的痛苦，这是卑鄙的。
And he's confronted in the car park by Shannon. He starts to argue with John about ownership of the foot. In fact, Shannon wanted to get custody of the foot. He wanted to take on tour. And finally, Wysnant and Wood decided to settle their dispute on a daytime TV show, Judge Mathis. Speaking in front of a live audience, Shannon Wysnant makes a case that John Wood's leg really belonged to him because he had bought it at an auction. Well, as that auction man said before he started, all sales are final, you know.
他在停车场被香农拦住了。他开始与约翰争论这只脚的所有权。事实上，香农想获得这只脚的监护权。他想带着它去巡回展出。最后，威斯南特和伍德决定在日间电视节目《马西斯法官》（Judge Mathis）上解决他们的纠纷。在现场观众面前，香农·威斯南特提出理由说，约翰·伍德的腿确实属于他，因为他是在拍卖会上买的。嗯，正如那位拍卖师在开始前所说，所有销售都是最终的，你知道。
Like this used to call a math or sample for $1 million in it and it falls out. Nobody's gonna want to give it back and that's considered content. I frankly you're right, sir. Both these men present their case before the TV judge, Judge Mathis. Shannon says, the rules of the auction were all sales are final and therefore anything that's in the grill belongs to me. And John Wood says, excuse me, that's my foot. You can't be buying
就像这曾经被称为数学样本，里面有100万美元，然后它掉出来了。没有人会想要把它还回去，那被认为是内容。坦率地说，你是对的，先生。这两个人都向电视法官马西斯法官陈述了他们的案件。香农说，拍卖规则是所有销售都是最终的，因此烤架里的任何东西都属于我。而约翰·伍德说，对不起，那是我的脚。你不能买
my foot. How did the TV judge come down on this? What was the ruling, Bruce? He found in favor of John Wood. But he also recognized that Shannon did have a legitimate claim of ownership, as he had argued. And so he ruled that the foot could be returned to John, but that Shannon should be compensated to the sum of, I think, about $5,000, which wasn't a bad return on his initial couple of dollars for which he paid. But it does reveal that you don't necessarily own things out right.
我的脚。电视法官对此有何裁决？布鲁斯，裁决是什么？他判决约翰·伍德胜诉。但他也承认，正如香农所辩称的那样，他确实拥有合法的拥有权主张。因此，他裁定这只脚可以归还给约翰，但香农应该获得赔偿，金额我想大约是5000美元，这对他最初支付的几美元来说，回报还不错。但这确实表明，你并不一定完全拥有东西。
You would think that you own your own body, and therefore no one can claim ownership over it. But actually, you can't do with your body as you wish. In Roman law, a lot of our legal systems are based on Roman law. There's a phrase called just uptending, which means the right to do as you wish with something. And that's the ultimate form of ownership, to the extent that if you own something out right, you could even destroy it if you want. But you can't do with your body as you wish because you can't destroy your body.
你会认为你拥有自己的身体，因此没有人可以声称拥有它。但实际上，你不能随心所欲地对待你的身体。在罗马法中，我们的许多法律体系都基于罗马法。有一个短语叫“just utendi”，意思是随心所欲地使用某物的权利。这是所有权的终极形式，以至于如果你完全拥有某物，你甚至可以在需要时销毁它。但你不能随心所欲地对待你的身体，因为你不能销毁你的身体。
Suicide is illegal in many legal systems. And you can't sell your organs. You can't sell bits of your body. So if you were the owner, you would be able to do that financial trial and section. And that's why I think the mummified foot is such an intriguing example of what happens when you get a clash between intuitions about ownership and actually the legal status of a bill of transfer as Shannon rightly points out. So my point is that the ownership which we intuitively think we have over our bodies
在许多法律体系中，自杀是非法的。而且你不能出售你的器官。你不能出售你身体的一部分。所以如果你是所有者，你将能够进行那种财务审判和部分。这就是为什么我认为木乃伊化的脚是一个如此引人入胜的例子，说明当你对所有权的直觉与转让票据的实际法律地位发生冲突时会发生什么，正如香农正确指出的那样。所以我的观点是，我们直觉上认为我们对身体拥有的所有权
is actually contestable from a legal point of view. You know, and this was a crazy story involving the leg, but you can see in, in many other prosaic domains that we have these clashing notions of, of ownership, not just when it comes to our bodies, but I feel like I own the apartment that I'm renting because I live there. You know, my landlord, of course, would feel differently. That's right. And of course, lease ownership is another example. You don't really own your lease car until you've made that fine payment. And who owns the moon and who owns various parts of space? I mean, these are things which are governments are still fighting over.
从法律角度来看实际上是可以争论的。你知道，这是一个涉及腿的疯狂故事，但你可以看到在许多其他平淡的领域，我们有这些相互冲突的所有权概念，不仅仅是关于我们的身体，但我感觉我拥有我租的公寓，因为我住在那里。你知道，我的房东当然会有不同的感觉。没错。当然，租赁所有权是另一个例子。在你支付那笔最终款项之前，你并不真正拥有你的租赁汽车。谁拥有月球，谁拥有太空的各个部分？我的意思是，这些是政府仍在争论的事情。
They have these treaties. But at one point, I think Russia tried to plan to flag on the bottom of the Arctic. And so there are areas which are still in dispute. And that's exactly the reason that ownership has Jeremy Benson, the philosopher, pointed out. There's nothing written in nature to tell you who owns what. It really comes down to conventions. In 2018, the artist Banksy sold a painting titled Girl with Balloon. I want to play you a news clip of what happened at the auction.
他们有这些条约。但在某一点上，我想俄罗斯试图计划在北极底部插旗。所以有些地区仍然存在争议。这正是所有权的原因，正如哲学家杰里米·边沁（Jeremy Bentham）指出的那样。自然界中没有任何东西写着告诉你谁拥有什么。这实际上归结为惯例。2018年，艺术家班克西（Banksy）卖出了一幅名为《气球女孩》（Girl with Balloon）的画。我想给你播放一段关于拍卖会上发生的事情的新闻片段。
A jaw-dropping moment, a Banksy painting sells at auction for $1.4 million. The gauvel drops and so does the painting. The painting drops with the gauvel. What exactly happens, Bruce? What happened was when the gauvel dropped, the painting seemed to kick into action and slowly descended into a hidden, threshing machine that Banksy had built into the bottom of the display. And literally, the picture was shredded in front of the whole audience, gasping and dismay
一个令人瞠目结舌的时刻，一幅班克西的画在拍卖会上以140万美元的价格售出。木槌落下，画也随之落下。画随着木槌落下。布鲁斯，到底发生了什么？发生的事情是，当木槌落下时，画似乎开始运作，并缓慢地下降到一个隐藏的粉碎机中，班克西把它内置在展示架的底部。字面上看，这幅画在全场观众面前被粉碎了，他们倒吸一口凉气，感到沮丧
as this valuable piece of art was spontaneously destroyed in front of their very eyes. But what Banksy was doing, and this is very typical of him, he challenges us to examine what do we mean by ownership. Because he never claims ownership for anything, and he challenges us each time to rethink about what it is to say that you actually own property. There are also other news events in some ways that bring into focus that contested notions of ownership. I'm thinking of what happened in 2001 after the Taliban took control of Afghanistan.
因为这件珍贵的艺术品在他们眼前自发地被摧毁了。但班克西所做的是，这对他来说非常典型，他挑战我们去审视我们所说的所有权是什么意思。因为他从不声称拥有任何东西，他每次都挑战我们重新思考说你实际上拥有财产意味着什么。还有其他新闻事件在某些方面使所有权的争议概念成为焦点。我想到的是2001年塔利班控制阿富汗后发生的事情。
They decided they now had possession of the country and they destroyed two statues of the Buddha that had been constructed in the sixth century. Their reasoning followed the idea that if you own something, you can do whatever you like to it up to and including destroying it. And of course, when they did it, the world was absolutely aghast. Yeah. And of course, if you trace back into the history of old countries, imperialism, who owns a country when you invade it and take it over, and then can you ask for things back when
他们决定他们现在拥有这个国家，并摧毁了两座建于六世纪的佛像。他们的推理遵循这样一个想法：如果你拥有某物，你可以对它做任何你想做的事，包括摧毁它。当然，当他们这样做时，全世界都感到震惊。是的。当然，如果你追溯到旧国家的历史，帝国主义，当你入侵并接管一个国家时，谁拥有这个国家，然后当
the times of time turn again? For example, the British Museum is faced with a crisis that many of its collections. A lot of the indigenous people are requiring the back. And again, this is also an issue in the US. And who owns things? Is it taken by force? It really is a minefield. I'm wondering here if we can extrapolate this to an even bigger stage, Bruce. Think about the point at which Native American tribes forced came into contact with European settlers, part of what followed stem from the fact that they had very different notions of what constituted
时代变迁时，你可以要求归还东西吗？例如，大英博物馆面临着许多藏品的危机。许多原住民要求归还。同样，这也是美国的一个问题。谁拥有东西？它是被武力夺取的吗？这确实是一个雷区。布鲁斯，我想知道我们是否可以将此推断到一个更大的舞台上。想想美洲原住民部落被迫与欧洲定居者接触的那一刻，随之而来的部分原因源于他们对什么构成了
ownership. Yes, so this is the famous transaction for owning Manhattan, the island of Manhattan, for apparently something like $26. And the reason that this is no worthy is that it wasn't really a fair trade because in order to be a fair trade, it has to be a mutually agreed convention about who owns what. Now, if the Indians who didn't have a concept of ownership in that sense that the land can be owned, to them, this looks like an easy deal. People are willing to give you money for something that can't be owned. But of course, from the European perspective,
所有权有着非常不同的概念。是的，这就是著名的拥有曼哈顿岛的交易，显然大约是26美元。值得注意的是，这不是一个公平的交易，因为要成为公平的交易，必须就谁拥有什么达成相互同意的惯例。现在，如果那些没有那种土地可以被拥有的所有权概念的印第安人，对他们来说，这看起来像是一笔容易的交易。人们愿意为你无法拥有的东西付钱。但当然，从欧洲的角度来看，
land is exactly the sort of thing that you could know, not right. So they saw it as a fair transaction. But it does point to the fact that it's a concept. It's a convention. It's something that has to be mutually agreed. And if both sides don't understand the terms, then it's not really a valid transaction. Hmm. I'm thinking of this poem I read some time ago.
土地正是你可以拥有的那种东西。所以他们认为这是一笔公平的交易。但这确实指出了这样一个事实，即它是一个概念。它是一个惯例。它是必须相互同意的东西。如果双方都不理解条款，那么它就不是真正的有效交易。嗯。我想到我前段时间读过的一首诗。
It's actually from the ancient Sanskrit Sanskrit from many hundreds of years ago From all your granaries a loaf of bread in all your palace only half a bed Can man use more and do you own the rest? So it seems to me that human beings have been wrestling with questions of ownership bruise for a very very long time Yes, I think they have and if you think back to Buddhism and the disavowment of materialist things, the Buddha certainly talked about the notion of the self as being a kind of illusion in many ways, and that we try to make it manifest through the possessions that we own. And you don't have to be spiritual to recognize that there's something to this. If you think about the way that we spend such a short period of time on this planet,
它实际上来自几百年前的古梵文。从你所有的粮仓里拿出一块面包，在你所有的宫殿里只占半张床。人能用更多吗？你拥有其余的吗？所以在我看来，人类长期以来一直在与所有权问题作斗争，布鲁斯。是的，我想他们有。如果你回想佛教和对物质事物的否定，佛陀确实谈到了自我作为一种幻觉的概念，在许多方面，我们试图通过我们拥有的财产来体现它。你不必是精神上的，也能认识到这一点。如果你想想我们在地球上度过如此短暂的时间的方式，
we know we're not going to be around, and yet why are we so preoccupied with owning these things, and we can't stop ourselves doing it. The research sort of backs this up. That once you've reached a comfortable level, then the additional wealth that you consume doesn't buy you proportionally the same amount of happiness. And yet, of course, that's not where people end up. They keep on this treadmill. There's always someone who seems to have an edge over us and there's always a goal to aim for. And whilst that can be a real driver for innovation and entrepreneurship and all those other things, and that's great. The trouble is it actually comes a cost to everyone on the planet.
我们知道我们不会长久存在，但为什么我们如此专注于拥有这些东西，而我们无法阻止自己这样做。研究在某种程度上支持了这一点。一旦你达到了舒适的水平，那么你消费的额外财富并不能按比例为你带来同样多的幸福。然而，当然，这并不是人们最终停留的地方。他们继续在这台跑步机上。总有人似乎比我们有优势，总有一个目标可以追求。虽然这可以成为创新、创业和所有其他事情的真正驱动力，这很好。问题是它实际上对地球上的每个人都造成了代价。
Bruce Hood is the author of Possessed. Why we want more than we need. Bruce, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, I had a great time. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, Laura Quarelle and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
布鲁斯·胡德是《占有：为什么我们想要的超过我们需要》（Possessed: Why we want more than we need）的作者。布鲁斯，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢，我玩得很开心。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
Our unsung heroes this week are Brian Carberry and Clay Tweedle. They are the makers of the documentary, Finder's Keepers. Bruce Hood first heard of the story about Shannon Wiesnant and John Wood through this movie. The film is riveting and dives much deeper into the story than we had time for. Thank you Brian and Clay. For more hidden brain be sure to subscribe to our newsletter. You can sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. If you'd like to support our work please go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
我们本周的无名英雄是布莱恩·卡伯里（Brian Carberry）和克莱·特威德尔（Clay Tweedle）。他们是纪录片《寻宝者》（Finder's Keepers）的制作人。布鲁斯·胡德第一次通过这部电影听说了香农·威斯南特和约翰·伍德的故事。这部电影非常引人入胜，比我们有时间讲述的更深入地挖掘了这个故事。谢谢布莱恩和克莱。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请务必订阅我们的时事通讯。你可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 注册。如果你想支持我们的工作，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。